bonjour tout le monde c'est drôle à
briser la glace est de fait vraiment une
expression culturelle j'ai déjà un grand
africain la semaine passée saab au
marché alors pour commencer il faut
qu'il fasse une confidence je sais pas
pour vous mais moi car j'étais jeune
c'était ma mère qui me couper les
cheveux bien chaque fois c'est est un
peu traumatisant c'était pas une
expérience la faune jaillissaient des
cachets deux adolescents ben j'ai
commencé à voir des petits jobs commence
à faire un peu d'argent mon premier
geste indépendance ça a été d'aller au
salon coiffure mais globe j'ai choisi le
plus gros salon coiffure et québec
quilles puis j'ai appelé j'ai pris un
niveau avec sabrina tombe en amour avec
un amour le coup de foudre
c'est une fois de rendez-vous troisième
rendez vous sabrina m'a trahi
j'ai su que ça plaît pas sabrina mechati
puisqu'elle avait quitté le salon fait
que cet art commence quand je suis
devenu un artiste en arts visuels
un premier travail c'était travailler
avec un salon de coiffure au saguenay
je suis allée bon le bois fin puis j'ai
dit j'ai raconté mon histoire j'ai dit
que je ferais un échange avec toi je
vais te cobayes par un tas tout les 3
watts atteindre plus de phase i de la
coloration des colorations disposition
et de couleurs tout ce qu'ils voulaient
après chaque peinture je veux faire
prendre en photo une semaine après tu
vas me raser les cheveux par couleur dit
on va faire une exposition dans ton
salon de coiffure avec les tables ou que
j'avais fait mes cheveux se gardera
quelques tableaux fait que j'avais l'air
de tout pendant un an
c'est assez étrange qu'un salaire d'un
tout petit cheval épicerie la scéne
aventure vous déjà mais pas la main
jaune parce que c'est me vrais cheveux
c'était pas une perruque
j'avais pas de là d'un punk parce que
michael mois qu'elle avait fait tout les
enfants les enfants même voie avec des
grands ducs
je te promets pour expliquer aux parents
après ben écoute oui c'est un travail
d'artiste pee wee
ça fait une sainte alors mon rapport
avec l'art mon rapport à ma vie
quotidienne à quelque chose qui m'avait
affecté quand j'étais jeune avait changé
et ça en travaillant avec une entreprise
alors je me suis dit comment est ce
qu'on peut faire ça plus grande échelle
alors j'ai décidé de monter une
exposition avec dix mille roses rouges
les dix mille roses rouges mais je
recevais à chaque deux semaines j'en
recevais des centaines qui moi je les
travaille et une fougue qui était séché
alors pour les faire sécher encore là
j'ai fait des ententes avec des
entreprises qui peuvent donc genre
apporter des roses rouges avaient
plusieurs douzaines de roses rouges à
chaque deux semaines je reparte avec
celle qui était séché alors vous
imaginez qu'un on est chez le dentiste
jean rouch à quelle date
monsieur blanchet avez vous vu nos
belles roses on travaille avec un
artiste qui va faire quelque chose avec
ça donc ça devrait un peu surréaliste
puis en même temps dans un bureau de
dentiste ailleurs de trois douzaines de
roses dans la salle d'attenté
mais inévitablement des chances par le
personnel salah de du groupe vantis
devait dire ben oui c'est un travail
sonore c'est ce qui gêne ni porter ça
ils vont faire une exposition avec ça
alors tranquillement le geste quotidien
devenez un endroit pour parler d'art et
ça ça devrait intéresser qu'un lorsqu'on
vous au dépanneur pour acheter notre
billet de loterie
puis qu'on se retrouve puis un grosse
douzaine de rose et qu'on se retrouve à
parler d'art il ya quelque chose de
fondamental pour nous toucher à ce
moment donc évidemment avec les roses va
récupérer j'ai fait une exposition donc
j'ai pris les pétales pour faire des
tableaux de grande dimension
j'ai pris les litiges pour faire des
sculptures j'ai pris les feuilles que
j'ai broyé pour faire un pigment où ça
donc je vais monter une exposition avec
ça maintenant
dans ce cas-là entreprises d'état s'est
passé comment est-ce qu'on peut engager
l'entreprise dans le processus
artistique
j'ai eu la chance de grandir se poser
mon lac saint jean saint filthy ou gmf
des six artistes puis j'aurais fait de
choisir six entreprises locales et ils
travaillent ensemble pendant deux
semaines et là on a eu du jeu
agen possible une peintre qui a
travaillé avec un cultivateur de cols du
ca alors vous imaginez les changes on
commence taille exceptionnelle
on a eu une performeuse que travailler
avec une école primaire des classes
d'écoles primaires et on ait eu entre
autres un bidouilleur d'électronique un
artiste qui bideau et l'électronique 95
réparateur de télévisions qui est allé
faire des prises de sons outre saint
félicien et que placer des diffuseurs
dans les bouches d'égout de la ville et
l'eau les gens pensaient qu'il y avait
un seul bourse qui sortait ou un aigle
alors voyez tout d'un coup il va comme
toute une vie en dessous de la ville
dispose c'était magnifique alors cette
conception loeb ça fait déjà plusieurs
années
cette consigne sur la normale mais
l'artiste là c'était l'artiste avec un
grand le grand créateur de son oeuvre
ben moi je lai à l'encontre de tout ce
que je faisais intervenir l'entreprise
dans le processus artistique
donc ça devenait savait créer autre
chose plus récemment avec un centre
d'artistes juste en bas de la côte 6 ap
la chambre blanche
on a commencé la chambre blanche c'est
un artiste qui reçoit des artistes de
l'étranger en résidence et c'est des
artistes qui utilise une nouvelle
technologie
donc on imagine l'idée de jumeler le
temps d'une soirée
un artiste qui utilise une certaine
technologie avec utilisé dans un travail
artistique donc dès ce titre sa
recherche d'esthétique et de sens et de
le faire travailler avec une entreprise
qui utilise la même technologie une
technologie similaire dans un contexte
commercial alors que l'on eut des
jumelages un peu impossible un artiste
brésilien qui avait fait une oeuvre géo
spatialisé encore qu'on voyait juste sur
son téléphone dans un lieu précis avec
une entreprise de géo spatialisation qui
utilisent les données entre autres qui
avait fait toute la répartition des
défis des fonds qui ont été envoyés en
haïti
les financeurs pour voir à quel endroit
largement été dépassées donc c'était
assez exceptionnel comme mélange onu un
artiste japonais qui faisaient de la
vidéo minimale et outils en petit format
qu'on est jumelée avec le directeur de
production du moulin à images d'hier est
en forme
donc on essaie de créer des chocs comme
ça pour contaminer contaminer les
pratiques
un de ceux qui est assez fou si c'était
un autre artiste japonais que sa place
aux canaux lui ce qu'il faisait
ils construisaient des robots qui
peignait à sa place la cph là il
maintient ses dires il ya un super
centre de robotique ndrc laval ont le
jumelé avec david cette embauche qui
était un ingénieur mécanique spécialisée
dans la résolution de problèmes
robotique est entre autres avec l'été
avec l'aide le concept du double pendule
qui le concept qui étaient utilisés par
l'artiste japonais donc sacrés comme ça
d espèce de mélange et on a essayé de
voir qu'elle commença puisse contaminer
ses pratiques le plus récemment on a
commencé à travailler avec une
entreprise près de québec qui est une
entreprise d'équarrissage donc eux ils
reçoivent des matières animales
ils les transforment ils font des
produits dérivés avec ça cette
entreprise de avait souhaité favoriser
l'engagement de ses employés d'en donner
un peu plus de dynamisme qui comprennent
un peu plus l'importance de leur travail
pour qu'ils étaient mauvais non ils
voulaient juste aller chercher d'autres
choses créer un autre sentiment faits
qui sont venus nous voir pour qu'on
organise des activités complètement flyé
avec deux eaux alors on a décidé de
jumeler une gestionnaire avec un conteur
d'histoires la gestionnaire fait fait le
synopsis d'un compte qui était la chaîne
de valeurs de l'organisation
la chaîne de valeur c'est quand on prend
les matières premières le fonde sur des
matières premières le transport la
transformation la distribution du
produit au consommateur
et qu'est ce que fait le consommateur
avec et ça ça vaut jusqu'à prendre aussi
les voisins du sinn donc à le faire un
compte avec tout ça plein le compteur et
s'est mise en bouche puis l'oeil a
raconté cette histoire là aux employés à
imaginer
c'était complètement fou il lui est fait
cela il dit ok il ya françois picard
l'île voisine où des voisins
évidemment de lusine qui partent en
vacances avec leur fille mélanie
cuirette pic s'en vont famille
recomposée s'en vont début de vacances
ils vont préparer leurs vacances alors
ils vont ils vont voir un fignole ils
vont chez le boucher ils vont restera là
chaque fois qu'ils arrivent quelque part
il ya un camion de l'entreprise qui
vient chercher des matières ou qui vient
emporté
alors tout ça ça a été de montrer un peu
comment l'importance de l'étape de
transformation où les employés étaient
évidemment bel autres que de combat
quand tu prends du dugas du bois
l'employé ghislain qui s'appelait qui
lui est chargé d'ouvrir la porte de
l'usiné
quelques camions rendre ferme la porte
le camion d'un vide ou laporte camion ça
rend la peau 1 c'est assez basique comme
job mais quand on compare ghislain au
portier du château frontenac est le
justin bieber droite et tout d'un coup
il y avait délivré le permis aux autres
femmes c'est magnifique à voir
alors on a magnifié de manière
complètement folle l'importance du
travail en lui donnant une valeur
pendant la touche et une émotion une
autre activité que vous avez reçus tout
à l'heure on a fait un journal le
journal il domaine l'entreprise
d'équarrissage en chair et en os mais le
journal c'est toute démarche est
complètement loufoque qui décrivent une
situation si l'entreprise fermés le
lendemain matin
et l'on retrouve une course de kayak
complètement débile qui fine des
canadiens qui finit dans des viscères
animal un parfum qui est lancé à ce à
audard de dab autres boucherie dans un
paquet de nouvelles non plus faute comme
ça et mais qui sont quand même peu
importe crédit mis mes proches et à la
fin de journal on vient d'écrire les
performances de l'organisation qui vient
en fait expliqué pourquoi six manches et
l'aide arrive pas c'est parce que
l'organisation est performante et donc
ça ce journal les impôts il faut partir
avec qui renaissait dans leur famille
pour commencer à diffuser cette
information là donc cédé par des moyens
comme éclaté comme celle créatif pour
dubaï votre travail est important mais
il faut le présenter de façon éclatée de
façon dynamique
qu'est ce qui se passe on environnement
travail
alors la menace aussi l'avènement entre
le sens de la sensibilisation au niveau
sonore
alors ce qu'on a fait si l'on a demandé
à un artiste en art audio de venir faire
des prises de sons dans l' usine et de
faire des compositions avec ça les
compositions les eaux rendu disponible
sur internet que les employés puissent
faire encore les et ça leur
famille alors imaginez-vous l'ado qui
fêtait sa ses amis designs ça c'est dans
l'usiné de mon père et son camp là on a
présenté son employé dans un contexte
très feutrée en dehors de lusine court
extrait fils tripp en 2001 niveau sonore
cas dans les usines et lui sont rendus
compte de ce qu'ils avaient dans leur
environnement de travail
c'était en dessous des seuils légal ou
est ce qu'ils doivent porter des
protections évidemment mais mais c'était
quand même préféré c'est affecter leur
humeur le stress l'offre leur santé donc
on lise ils sont rendu compte tout d'un
coup que l'environnement travail
physique qu'on associe que quand tu
rates à l'usiné s'assoit sur haulotte
est habitué à tout d'un coup il y avait
une ampleur qui était démesurée donc on
a encore le magnifier un point à un
autre
une partie leur environnement de travail
pour leur faire rendre compte que
finalement bien il y avait peut-être
quelque chose à faire avec ça et donc
lorsque je vous ai raconté en quelques
minutes ses 15 ans de travail faisait
pas tout raconter les tentatives qui ont
échoué
ça ça peut être long mais ça c'est des
réussites et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que tout ça c'est pour moi qui a
inventé ce ça
cette façon de voir le d'un artiste on
vous retrouve ça jusqu'à la renaissance
depuis la renaissance on était capable
vraiment de voir que l'artiste prenait
une nouvelle fonction dans la société
est ce que je me souhaite aujourd'hui
c'est que les artistes mais il reprenne
la place qui leur revient dans la
société pour qu'on veut on puisse vivre
une deuxième renaissance lorsque les
artistes ce sont des gens qui vont venir
it's kind les fondements de notre
société et les fonctions notre
fonctionnement et la manière dont on vit
dans le quotidien
merci